what would you
place your biggest hope for productivity
increases on because
you kind of said at a high level ai but
if i were to think about what has been
so revolutionary
in the last 10 years i would have 15
years
and thinking about the internet i would
say things like
uh hopefully i'm not saying anything
ridiculous but everything from
wikipedia to twitter so like these kind
of
websites not so much ai
but like i would expect to see some kind
of big productivity
increases from just the connectivity
between people
and uh the access to and for more
information
yeah well that's another area i've done
quite a bit of research on actually
is these free goods like wikipedia
facebook
twitter zoom we're actually doing this
in person but
almost everything else i do these days
is is online um
the interesting thing about all those is
most of them
have a price of zero you know what do
you pay for wikipedia maybe like a
little bit for the electrons to come to
your house
it's basically zero right um take a
small pause and say i donate to
wikipedia often you should too because
they're
for you yeah so but what does that do
mean for gdp gdp
is based on the price and quantity of
all the goods things bought and sold
if something has zero price you know how
much it contributes to gdp
to a first approximation zero so
these digital goods that we're getting
more and more of we're spending more and
more hours a day
consuming stuff off of screens little
screens big screens
that doesn't get priced into gdp it's
like they don't exist
that doesn't mean they don't create
value i get a lot of value from
watching cat videos and reading
wikipedia articles and listening to
podcasts
even if i don't pay for them so we've
got a mismatch there
now in fairness economists since simon
kuznets invented gdp and productivity
all those statistics back in the 1930s
he recognized he in fact said this is
not a measure of well-being this is not
a measure of welfare
it's a measure of production but almost
everybody
has kind of forgotten that he said that
and they just use this like how well off
are we what was gdp last year was 2.3
growth or whatever um that is
how much physical production but it's
not
the value we're getting we need a new
set of statistics and i'm working with
some colleagues avi collis and others
to develop something we call gdp-b gdp b
measures the benefits you get not the
cost
if you get benefit from zoom or
wikipedia or facebook
then that gets counted in gdp b even if
you pay
zero for it so you know back to your
original point
um i think there is a lot of gain over
the past decade
in these digital goods that doesn't
that doesn't show up in gdp doesn't show
up in productivity by the way
productivity is just defined as gdp
divided by hours worked
so if you mismeasure gdp you mismeasure
productivity by the exact same amount
that's something we need to fix i'm
working with the statistical agencies
to come up with a new set of metrics and
uh you know over the coming years i
think we'll see
we're not going to do away with gdp it's
very useful but we'll see a parallel set
of accounts
that measure the benefits how difficult
is it to get that b
in the gdp it's pretty hard i mean the
thing one of the reasons it hasn't been
done before
is that you know you can measure at the
cash register what people pay for stuff
but how do you measure what they would
have paid like what the value is that's
a lot harder
you know how much is wikipedia worth to
you that's what we have to answer
and to do that what we do is uh we can
use online experiments we do massive
online choice experiments
we ask hundreds of thousands now
millions of people to do
lots of sort of a b tests how much would
i have to pay you to give up wikipedia
for a month how much would i have to pay
you to stop using your
phone and in some cases it's
hypothetical in other cases we actually
enforce it which is
kind of expensive like we we pay
somebody thirty dollars to stop using
facebook and we see if they'll do it and
some people will give it up for ten
dollars some people won't give it up
even if you give them a hundred dollars
and then you get a whole demand curve
you get to see what all the different
prices are
and what how much value different people
get and not surprisingly different
people have different values we find
that
women tend to value facebook more than
men old people tend to value it a little
bit more than young people i was
interesting i think young people maybe
know about other networks that i don't
know the name of that are
better than facebook um and uh
and so you get to see these like these
patterns but you know every person's
individual
and then if you add up all those numbers
you start getting a uh
an estimate of the value okay first of
all that's brilliant is this
uh work that you will soon eventually be
published yeah well there's a version of
it in the proceedings of the national
academy of sciences
about i think we call it massive online
choice experiments i i should have
should remember the title but it's on my
website
so yeah we have some more papers coming
out on it but the first one uh
is already out
you